à plaisir les pompiers s'activaient pour
éteindre cet incendie dans un bâtiment
désaffecté
pas de panique il s'agissait d'un
exercice pendant une semaine 84
sapeurs-pompiers ont bénéficié d'une
formation continue en conditions réelles
une opportunité assez rare au cours de
leur formation initiale et au cours de
leur entraînement les jours de casernes
ils font tous partie il fonde la
technique violence ils font de la
reconnaissance ils vont faire du
traitement les fumées aujourd'hui ça
permet de le mettre tout en actions au
même moment donc en fait c'est plein de
petites techniques plein de petits
outils qui travaillent au quotidien
aujourd'hui peuvent mettre en action sur
un feu réel et en chine l'année les
sapeurs pompiers doivent s'introduire
dans ce dédale de couloirs combattre les
feux et se couvrir les éventuelles
victimes une équipe reste à l'extérieur
en soutien en tenue rouge
les formateurs observent leur
comportement attention une sonnerie
retentit signe que la bonbonne d'oxygène
évident exercice où nous ce pompier doit
sortir quelques minutes plus tard la
manoeuvre se termine bilan désolé qu'ils
sont à temps de fêtes et à la victime a
été retrouvée secouru en charge par les
équipes extérieures pour les formateurs
certains points restent tout de même
améliorée retour c'est qu'il ya encore
du travail à faire notamment sur la
progression et la taille de fumée c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas forcément
abordé dans l'es10 fait différents
guides et puis bah la pratique a rien de
mieux pour justement après laurent 2e
ronde sur intervention
les stagiaires pourront continuer à
s'exercer tout au long de la journée
si manoeuvre au total ce bâtiment
désaffecté appartient à l'hôpital
charcot son personnel de sécurité a pu
profiter également de cette opportunité
on a pu aussi se connaître entre les
agents de sécurité l'hôpital charcot et
les pompiers le plaisir qui fait qu'ils
demandent d'intervenir on se connaîtra
mutuellement on se fera connaît
confiance mutuellement et aussi j'aurais
passé les messages importants des
informations que nous on a besoin
lors de nos interventions un système
gagnant gagnant en france elle les
incendies causent la mort de près de 800
personnes chaque année